the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome trash fans to Ultimate moves a
fun and exciting chess event we host
here in St Louis at the St Louis chess
club and the world chest Hall of Fame we
have uh pitted together two teams very
explosive teams team rex versus Team
Alex first of all I'm going to start
with Team Rex and present our captains
are leaders of the two teams Rex
singfield of course is the co-founder of
the St Louis chess club 15 years of
revitalizing American and World Chess I
might say and also it's your birthday
happy birthday Rex
and Alex Alex careford is a good friend
of the Saint Louis chess club for over
nine years he is also representing
Edward Jones and uh you're also on the
U.S chess trust so thank you very much
Alex for everything you do for American
chess and for the St Louis chess club
well guys any final words before we
start this whole battle Rex I'll start
with you
oh gosh final words I don't know what to
say to you Alex I'm thinking of humming
some funeral dirch
there's going to be a lot of Trash Talk
guys for the next couple of hours Alex
I mean I was taught growing up to
respect my elders but today I I might
have to make an exception here so we'll
see what happens that's a good start
that's a good start we should also
discuss uh the format perhaps as we get
ready to present the teams we have four
games uh game ten plus five seconds
after five moves both teams will rotate
players so we will be seeing a lot of
exciting players the best chess players
here in the United States as well as one
legendary Gary Kasparov who will be here
I'm not sure if he's already here but he
will be here and he will be giving dirty
looks to uh Rex for sure
if he's not
I'm I think Levon has something to say
about that
um what do you think about forfeiting a
team if they're late
I I think we're here for the show so we
should uh
show some Grace
I I like it lead with Grace I like it I
like it Levon all right well
we're still waiting for uh all the
players to arrive but before that
perhaps we will introduce the teams
we're going to start with Team Rex Rex
of course is the captain he has behind
him Fabiano caruana Levon aronian Lanier
Dominguez Sam Shanklin and Sam Savion a
lot of exciting players on this one
on team Alex we have Hikaru Nakamura
Gary kasprov Wesley so Jeffrey Sean and
Ray Robson a lot of exciting chess
coming your way a lot of Trash Talk
coming your way as well who should we
start with Hikaru what do you expect
from uh this following four games well I
mean I think based on the lineups were
big favorites so hopefully we'll win
every game
let's go all right let's take somebody
from the opposing team or team rex Fabi
you're leading the team how do you feel
about this matchup
I think we're clear favorites too
I mean why why would they be clear
favorites
maybe because they have Hikaru Ashley
Jeffrey and other players aren't even
professionals Gary and Hikaru I mean
they're not even professional chess
players anymore
but also Hikaru doesn't care about that
so it doesn't really matter
[Laughter]
Gary Kasparov has arrived our team our
true team leader inspiration welcome
welcome Gary
yeah you're on the other team Gary how
are you feeling about it I know you're
bringing a lot of competitiveness in
these matches
um I don't know uh yeah so I don't know
what to expect
so it was the I have to say that's
that's my first chance to move pieces on
the board since last year well I have to
say nobody knows what to expect from
this matches is going to be a lot of fun
a lot of trash talk we should probably
get going Rex Alex you guys are gonna
start
um all right well just a second
where is the Arbiter Chris bird do we
have the Arbiter with us
Chris bird
the Arbiter would you like to Brian
okay
team Alex Chris tell us the order of uh
play Team Alex after Alex is gonna go
Hikaru Gary Wesley Jeffrey then Ray
and for team rex he's gonna go
Fabi Lavon lenier Sam shankland and then
Sam Sevin
perfect
I guess we are ready to uh yes you guys
give up
fine
no
there we go all right 10 minutes plus
five seconds increment we're just about
to start we're just waiting for Brian
our official Arbiter for this event to
start a clock
good luck everybody
[Applause]
very aggressive style already employed
by uh Rex
Alex you've been actually training chess
960 for this event but you just found
out that you're actually playing chess
how did that impact your plans you know
it did impact them some um but I think
I'll be okay because I think that's my
fifth move
final move Rex
how are you feeling about the position
so far
okay
I agree yeah
we see Hikaru is uh
I just wasn't a bit confused about the
position
s
are we going to see it yes he went for
it
My Sacrifice
yes yes yes
we have some distinguished Spectators
around here no no don't run running away
don't run away yes sir you've been a
part of this many many years very tense
it's very tense how do they usually go
go about
well the biggest problem in this
competition is keeping the order
players are constantly playing out of
order you got to make that move the
second thing is the enthusiasm of the
teams is a reveal like you know like
so who's more enthusiastic in today's
matchup
Teamworks or team Alex Well what we'll
see is it builds up but it's like one of
those things when a blunder occurs like
everybody
but everybody oh there you are there you
are so uh and trash talking is uh is
required required so you got to think
about the trash talk mandatory yeah for
example in my opinion
from
delusions of adequacy
and we're trying to cure him it's not
that easy it's not working we he's been
a friend of ours for a long time
all right position is very very intense
at the moment the last move deep four by
Hikaru blue position white Oakland
I love it yeah
great great game so far
[Applause]
Gary happy with the position happy with
the sacrifices
[Applause]
a lot of imbalance in the position
definitely a type of position Gary
should enjoy
any thoughts about the position Gary
not yet
my opinion is super ships and an extra
pawn and an active King so active King I
like that yes
it's not going anywhere in that case
in the middle of the board
I said please don't Castle
passing the torch
oh I have no idea what's going on yeah
but I don't think we're doing badly I
think we're doing pretty good
no I think so I think it was a good
start
24.
party
[Applause]
I'm not sure about the legality of those
discussions but I guess everything goes
oh that was a long time ago
everything goes
afternoon
a lot of discussions going on
this side of the aisle what are you guys
talking about
strategy like after race
after race move then it's going to be
Alex so we're going to make it as easy
as possible
but you cannot trash talk your own
we didn't have time to prepare too much
opening but it is oh my goodness
all right well
um you're not the last one Ray is the
last one yeah definitely after rape do
you feel extra pressure Ray for uh being
the last one pass the torch to Alex
no we're just I'm just gonna put us in a
good position so we can finish them off
the next one good and simple yes
[Laughter]
they're extremely concentrated right now
a lot of focus going on a lot hanging on
the next couple of moves
[Applause]
right so you can cut the tension with a
knife right now yes
do you have a knife with you
no
another piece
Bobby
also trying to figure out what's uh
what's happening
okay very complex
fun game to start off with that's for
sure
but it's going to get more fun later oh
yes oh yes
how are we doing on time
eight minutes for team Alex for seven
minutes and 36 for team rex
Jeffrey
so much pressure
on your own Gary's team or Legend like
Gary
how do you feel about that how do you
feel about your five moves that are
about to come
uh well I'm not next up yet right now it
seems problematic but we'll see what
happens
any trash talking words for the opposing
team I know you've been pretty good at
that
uh I think it'll be a close match but
we'll win
strong words strong fighting words
somebody offered a draw whoa whoa whoa
no there was a draw for who offered a
draw
you can accept their resignation
no draw
who's paying your salary Brian
just wondering acquiring minds
oh my goodness well Rex definitely said
no draw will only accept the resignation
[Laughter]
foreign
so you're happy with that do you think
you're uh you're going to make any moves
in this game or it's going to be the
routing towards I think I'll be able to
make some moves we really have some
ideas here
still a fighting position I see you're
uh wandering tell us what do you feel
about
um
I want to play I don't think we should
but yes it took me a second to realize
what the other guys had in mind but yeah
I think this game is going to end before
I get to make a move uh prior to that I
actually thought so anyway but I thought
we were gonna win uh but no they
defended resourcefully differing
opinions
somebody says the game will go on
somebody says there's going to be a draw
a repetition somewhere I don't see the
repetition
I don't think we can do that
I don't think we can do moves
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hobby you're happy with the draw here
I'm not happy with the draw but okay
they escaped what can we do
but the game is not over why is
everybody saying this is going to be a
drop tell us Wesley is going to take the
pawn
and then he's going to
we're not going to tell him I think yeah
I think he sees you think he sees it
yeah
wait there's some discussions going on
if you want
if we want fighting words
that's a check all right
one more
Wesley's trying to escape early yeah
Donuts chess players are good with
numbers I thought they knew how to you
know we're good with numbers analytical
hype well maybe they need some Financial
advice exactly I agree with you there
thank you
yeah yeah no I mean it's I think I think
this might be winning for a while team
Alex is playing for a win but nobody
knows why
it works
so yeah
oh
my goodness
he's taking the jacket off
the jacket is off that's official the
jacket is off team Alex is playing for a
win but nobody understands why we were
thinking instead of Queen G8 Rook takes
E5 the consensus on the bench that was
the one right yeah that was the draw
that Lavon Lavon saw and expected
everybody to follow was Rook takes E5
okay so uh the decision to go Queen G8
and Bishop G5 is a shock ancient history
right now right how is the position
looking right
[Music]
big moment
don't worry your mistakes are coming up
Alex
it's coming
after Jeffrey we have Ray on Tim Alex
after Sam we have Sam sevion coming up
I am glad I don't have to untangle I'm
glad I don't have to untangle what's
happening right now it'll come with
it'll come to me in a little bit of a
different a different look I suppose
famous last words
all right big tense moment
Jeffrey's trying to find the PATH only
four minutes left
for team Alex against almost six minutes
for Dave rice Big Time advantage
[Music]
it's not good but
what about the time is that a factor are
you worried about it what about time I
worry about the opposition
it was a little unfortunately rookie
five we had the excellent position that
was a plan five and maybe play for a win
in that position I think it's just it's
it's we don't have a computer to check
the
exactly the evaluation but it seems like
after a rookie 55 and then 92
has no risk this is winning or not it's
another story but I was a Perpetual
blood cannot move the piece yeah yes we
had we had and what's the material uh
disadvantage at that point just a roof
it's 94.
yeah this is all pinned you know so
that's yeah that was a plan that was it
oh my goodness Wesley what did you do
about it Wesley that Rook takes C5 that
was your chance
but you know yeah I mean you mean it's
Rick's birthday after all
okay yes that's true no mercy from our
team no mercy Wesley come on get your
head in the game
peace up a very flamboyant King
or black
linear
haven't talked to you in a while how do
you feel feeling good about decision
yeah now I feel very good I think uh
before I'm in this rookie fight was
obviously a good chance but
of course Wesley is a young woman yeah
let's let's not forget that it's uh
Rex's birthday he actually said so he
rose to the occasion I think oh man
yeah he did he indeed
Rex are you feeling lucky on your
birthday
I think we're feeling fortunate
we also have the head of security right
here with us if the trash talk gets too
heated up are you going to intervene is
that a plan no you gotta stay out of
this this is for chess players and I am
definitely not a chess player I know how
to play but I'm not a chess player
that's not your main job you you also
been in a different lifetime a baseball
pitcher for the Saint Louis Cardinals
that's correct congratulations thank you
brother
keep doing the good work
I'm still waiting for the trash talk
when is that going to start uh it's been
going on a little bit on that side a
little bit on this side but it's
scattered for the moment
we need somebody to draw the first block
and then it's going to get heated up yes
rookie five
people are chattering about it yes
saying that was a winning position for a
while yeah do you agree with that
well now that I realized yeah yeah
probably I have to agree so yeah
probably my knight C6 was not the best
any reason why they didn't find
rotations
any reason
the reason is simple you know they they
understand that we're better players and
you know they behave accordingly I like
it yes
yes indeed
how many moves until we get the final
switch they've got one more move each
one more move
big final move
very classy immediately undermining
what is happening I like it yes you're
still not worried about that
adventurous King no
no I'm back to sleep now
[Laughter]
I like it yeah
the jacket was off
I had to defend my king what do you want
me to do it's stressful
you sweat a little bit yeah I mean I
think we're basically winning but that I
had to be extremely precise and if I
screwed up that the other team would
just never let me hear the end of it so
it was a little stressful but I'm fairly
confident I defended well it looks good
right now
the queen got trapped you see I saw it
yeah yeah on day six of the king is
active
you know I learned this this rule in uh
back house okay the safe King is the
king that doesn't have any pawns around
him or like pieces so he can you know
he's maneuvering around
so we have an extremely safe key trust
lessons 101. maybe you guys are watching
please take notes it's chess and back
house and back house okay yes
and now Sam is going to attack see so
not having pawns around those fires it's
actually playing in Black's favor
because you get an attack beautiful
attack yes very nice well also generally
extra piece helps
I'm not having
any pawns around your king make sure you
have the extra piece to back it up wise
words
what's happening guys ah it's just all
over it's been over since since Wesley
messed up
[Applause]
like a movie you asked which
are all by yourself
FFA is a four game matchup
they're really making you the culprit
for this one
no but we'll make gray refine
[Laughter]
we will say darling
you have just three more moves and then
yeah if
break and stay cool
that's a good sign
it's a chance it's a chat it's a chat
it's a chat
the only thing in here the next five
moves anything can happen
these are the critical moves right now
[Music]
Rex Gary is saying the next five moves
are the critical moves of the game how
how do you respond to that probably true
no pressure
I understand
thank you
Alex down to his last two minutes
no 40 seconds only
and Rex with two minutes and 35 seconds
this is going to go down in The Wire
there's not much time left
forget every move you make
five seconds
foreign
[Music]
going on because you're not allowed
to say moves that's true you can trash
talk but you cannot say marks
two more moves
two more moves is that correct two more
moves
played with only seven seconds on the
clock 12 right now after the five second
income
Rex pounces towards white screen
that's it
five moves
[Laughter]
yes because he weakened his position as
a result well done well done
five moves Hikaru is out Gary is not
happy
would you mind taking a seat
[Laughter]
I think it's only fair that Wesley has
to
I don't know I think
I think it's your turn
I need to make him
you like the position Wesley
[Applause]
quotations
[Laughter]
put me in Rex I mean I really want
Wesley to get mated so I'm tempted not
to play Queen she2 here but I'd like to
play the next game so there you go
[Applause]
how did you do in last year's first game
do you remember I don't remember
do you remember how you did last year in
the first game I think I won every game
what made perfect moves every time
that's that's how I recall it as well
that's how I last year this player was
very strong yeah it was very good John
yes yes
all right we're getting ready for uh the
next match I have to ask you Alex I mean
that was a tough one you guys had a
great position at one point everybody
was blaming Wesley but you as the team
leader what what do you tell we are a
team and you know we felt that it was
important to give one to Rex for his
birthday
don't expect it to happen again
all right
the trash talk is heating up guys and
we're just about to start the next game
is going to be Rex with the white pieces
against Alex with black pieces
players are getting ready it was a Tense
one very very tense went back and forth
a lot of exciting chess as we predicted
and a lot of trash talk as well we saw a
lot of
Mutiny within the teams we've seen
Wesley taking a lot of hits from his own
teammates we don't know exactly what's
going to happen in the next one but it's
getting heated up right now so we're
just finishing setting up
soon we're going to be ready to start
the next game
Alex I see you're taking a lot of space
you're trying to project a lot of
dominance over the chessboard is that
part of the strategy everything is a
part of the strategy absolutely Gotta
Give it this Gotta Give it our all this
time
well one thing I notice is that all the
players are behind Rex right now you
need to man your troops get them behind
you guys go behind your your team right
here
uh raid start yeah game on
oh okay okay
[Applause]
safe preserving the lead
not anymore
okay
have you been coaching Rex at all yeah
we looked at this variation
there's a lot of theory behind us a lot
of crap all proud
[Music]
yes yes
Chris will you uh give us the order for
a game two it's it's sort of exactly the
same team go in the same order but we
just have a different person following
Rex and Alex
so next up for team rex it's linear than
Sam Shanklin Sam Serbian then Fabi and
next up for team Alex it will be Jeffrey
rare Hikaru then Garrett thank you
Bobby you're uh you're going last
is that not going to play in your favor
sixth
yes last from it might be less
this is a huge opening success
huge opening success
Rex did you expect the caracon no I
didn't you've studied it along
throughout your career and to reach back
into my memory banks okay okay
last time I watched this I wish I looked
this place 20 years ago black was fun
this is
get some good lines coming up here got
some good lines
you see me like not knowing a thing that
they're saying
but look you have to you nod your head
you you look like you understand
everything very so it's important it's
important
thank you
how do we feel about the position not
good I think it's not the best uh
approach but it's still still probably
reasonably okay it's only a little bit
better for white Bobby called it a great
success uh why is that
well if you don't like if we were
playing the entire game would be a great
success but Rex and uh Rex and Alex have
to play play some moves it's mainly just
because black is uh lacking in space why
there's much more space there are easier
Moves In general to play cool thank you
for the insights
foreign
[Music]
yeah
nice memory test right there every
weapon born
at that time yeah but if I played Bishop
E7
is wrong
yeah exactly yeah it's hard when you
jumped in the chair okay yeah of course
you have no idea I know the problem is
you don't positions are all wrong
because D7 is also wrong B7 if you can
get it so it's like all the pieces
five
so much so bad because I bet it's
position where it has to you have to
prove the advantage right here you make
like one or two and actions it's
probably already back to equal
completely blocked
super focused right now the two players
linear and uh Jeffrey make too many
plans for both sides I mean you have
some Bishop moves you have a queen move
to I mean there's so many different
ideas here you can trade the knights I
mean why does so many plans so it's hard
to pick the right one okay
then you're sticking for such a short
time it's
different blend get in his head
we need it so that came right yep flat
game Jeffrey
I love our music
feeling good about the position right
now yes Bobby called it a great success
it's a great success great success okay
we're going to meet very soon
this Pawn on H6 makes me too excited
it makes me happier that I am alive okay
the young guys don't know how to play
against it see
exactly and they're talking about it in
Whispers and Analysis it just seems to
me that uh Team Alex is basically put
all the sins on the shoulders of Wesley
so
they wanted Wesley to recite but Wesley
was getting in some spike checks on the
way out there
so Wesley uh
Wesley finagled his way out but now the
question is how can Wesley deem himself
he's got to come in and make some really
good books boss moves boss moves
otherwise I think you have to step in
I mean you know uh duty calls you know
sometimes you just gotta step up
tomorrow and take care are you excited
about that oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah and I
was talking to Wesley about it he's
saying you know like hey I was former
world champion
did they have the final between Wesley
and Hikaru last year I'm trying to
remember because you were in Norway I
was in Norway world champion as you were
too it was uh against Magnus and I
remember this was so funny uh they're in
Oslo and all the little Norwegian
children had their faces painted with
face paint the Norwegian flag Wesley
destroyed nights and all of these kids
were there Norway
zip quiet that's probably right on their
cheeks
painful very painful Christian well
Wesley is feeling definitely good about
uh just 960. how about the position I
like white I like the fact that
everybody seems to like white in the ice
yeah the isolated queen palm positions
the idea is the more minor pieces that
are on the board is better for the play
with isolated Queen part so in this
moment we're thinking that the night is
going to a jump 94 tickle the bishop
Knight C5 tickle the B7 pawn and just
better development better pieces for
white the problem is the passive light
Square Bishop on D7 if you
magically trade off those light squared
Bishops that would be nice black would
be soaring this one would be beautiful
exactly so right now
team rex looking good team Alex needs to
make some repairs all right where's the
trash talking I know I know we're
getting there we're getting there
my birthday
Gary Gary what do you think about that
karpovian move Bishop B1 both carpooling
it's like they learn from carfa what's
going on Harper played his positions was
black only
yeah
probably at home would be Bishop to F1
third time
for the afternoon
[Music]
yeah so it's okay you know yes I forgot
I mean I have to take decisions
how are things uh Lavon how are things
the rumor on the street is that you're
suffering uh
feelings of
killings of adequacy
strong feelings of adequacy is it true
so yes sir yesterday was telling me
about the tournaments he won I started
with the Washington State Championship
he didn't know I told him yes sir in
your life you won one and a half turn
I said you forgot about the Washington
state junior Championship
oh my goodness so who paid for dinner
sleep happy dude
it was a good dinner it was a good day
so as an outsider looking in yeah sir
how do you feel about the performance of
the team leaders Alex and Friends
actually they've played decently they
really have they've kept the balance it
was really the the the teams the
All-Stars that have made the difference
Wesley was making the difference
you're the Difference Maker there's
something
any comeback for that Wesley
when you're right now everyone will get
there one day sooner or later
we can switch
[Laughter]
then we'd have over 50 of our team
non-professional players yes
over
I like it you like the fun yes they are
a professional or not professional
well they've been accusing you of not
being a professional chess player I
think my moods would be more
professional than Rey's
you know Ray was not accusing you no no
right Rey's being nice don't put it on
rate
yeah but he's actually misunderstood the
position a little bit some of the some
of the moves he's made so
I mean not so not so great but I mean
it's also a tough position if you don't
play the structure you don't know what
to do necessarily another other problem
[Laughter]
getting better or getting worse
I think the next five moves will decide
[Music]
yeah next five movies will decide the
game probably about maybe next time I
mean someone's gonna make a mistake you
know why Windsor we're completely fine
in the next five to ten minutes yes
let's say this is you've only safely
predicted unlikely that Rex will come
back okay okay
[Applause]
yes
yes oh
where is Michael oh yeah I love that
you're assuming here normally in the
back you're seeing the position yeah did
you see this bishop takes eight yeah I
was hoping he plays it because
yeah it's your turn
[Applause]
everything
yeah
and amongst the ranks here we're just
trying to figure out the uh
there's genius behind it but we're
trying to understand it
so Sam
[Laughter]
okay that was very good for him
he's gonna have to justify it but no
[Applause]
yeah
[Laughter]
Sam what was the point
I'm gonna tell you but I'm not supposed
to I had I had an idea here maybe it
doesn't work in fact I'm very confident
it does work but we'll see
yes thank you very much
I understand it he wants to win the
queen
[Laughter]
also want to win the queen but I don't
see it but for two ropes but we only
have one rope
[Music]
of the
results
through its 50 for both players right
now both teams down their last four
minutes
he's happy with the coin
are we happy birthday
fetch a very nice word thank you very
much I mean professional commentary
really raises your game is it from
Washington State yeah the Championships
yeah baby
Alex
vicious attack Brewing against your king
are you ready to to get the game I think
the sacrifice will not materialize for
team rex and that we are gonna we're
gonna see it turn around right here
we're getting up on time we're being
aggressive I like to play I Love It
beautiful prediction right there
Rex
how did you like the bishop sacrifice
Bishop takes H6 absolutely cool wins by
force
so you see it also yeah
they all see that's the one with
brilliant
my wife wanted to say a happy birthday
and you're going down
seven
[Applause]
that's uh it looks suspicious
Hikaru is asking Fabi for advice
[Applause]
it's interesting
perfect
[Music]
though
yeah of course
and make it immediately
well the queen is pinned
don't worry
I'm going to tell him
who's next
[Applause]
two more moves
bam what went wrong
that's what I've done I sucked on H6
that's what I missed because there are
lots of other details but I can also go
Knight G6 instead of um King fa because
he goes gives the piece and then puts
the queen on G5 I think there I have to
go Knight takes F7 so I was calculating
a lot but I missed this bishop back
around to G7
my new details
right now
very close to make a comeback
just get into Rex keep it directs
you have attack and uh Rex is gonna like
once but Rex is going to bring the bacon
home yes I Rook down it doesn't matter
there's a general feeling on the bench
is that uh shanky Panky
overlooks something with Bishop H6
so Sam is the culpriter on this one all
right yes he was the first one exactly
so the Baton got passed they're blaming
okay is that true sorry are you guys
blaming Sam for the attack we're a team
we never blame anybody action beautiful
I like that wait wait until the end of
the year wait until the end of the
competition Lavon is going to say I
played 20 oh
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so right now Gary with a big sacrifice
but this Rook D6 I mean explain it to us
Levon explained this move Rook 26 to us
we'll see
we'll see what happens if you take the
queen right away White's Queen was
trapped and there was a background
said there was Rook A8 was an issue
trapping the queen and the Checkmate
right you cannot defend the game so Rook
D6 was a beautiful
interpretation to to provoke Knight C4
and the queen could Escape 10 seconds 10
seconds right now for 10 seconds on the
clock anything can happen
right now
press that clock Rex that's played with
one second on the clock one second on
the clock
gave you a heart attack Bobby a slight
one yes but we're doing amazing we just
have to now run out of time and we're
doing great
the problem right would have lost yeah
no yeah I understood yeah sir yeah yes
a lot more Smiles on this side of the
aisle
come on
brilliant
[Applause]
there was a flag unfortunately
I predicted this this is the fruit of
our labor
things are hitting up Rex
that was a close score
it was a close call yeah I got lucky you
know you got to get lucky ones
game three is just about to come your
way we have an exciting match right now
one one a piece team rex versus Team
Alex it's explosive it's fun there's a
lot of trash talk and we're all having a
lot of fun around here
we have a replay going on right now
[Music]
we're doing a replay of the flag right
now let's see through the magic of
Television let's see what happened at
the end of game two
and that was it that's all she wrote
there was just simply too much pressure
in those last couple of seconds it's all
about the time it feels like the first
game you had a few seconds left now it's
on the shoe is on the other uh foot how
are you feeling going into game three
game three team Alex we got the momentum
we just have to keep it rolling keep the
clock on our side and we're gonna have a
good result
slow the bleeding down stop what they
have going is both is experimental
we're not going to translate that
let the games begin
all tied up going into the second half
of this
match
one a piece team rex versus Team Alex
Chris please announce the order for game
three yeah so for team rex it's going to
be linear then Sam Shanklin some Sabian
Fabi in Le bomb and then for team Alex
is going to be rare first then hikaro
Gary Wesley Jeffrey perfect
hopefully everybody heard that
I'm sure they're going to come back for
seconds
like if you play King City I just don't
understand the sequence yeah
yeah but also somehow this is a real
game again this is like somehow like
very normal
very strange
yeah it's very very similar yeah yeah
exactly yeah
Rex I thought you're a king's Indian
player you played the groomfield I do
that's a new one that's a new Wrinkle in
your repertoire you've been you've been
working yeah that's all I've played
lately
one year you nine you don't need the
fourth board here
[Laughter]
oh
okay
lilium so right now we're talking about
the potential Olympic team
based in St Louis Olympic team of St
Louis it's three of us Bobby Lanier and
I then Rey and then uh Liam
okay
Christian
okay we can uh bring your parents on a
bus from from Colombia from Colombia no
I he has work to do at school yes so he
can't play foreign
maybe warm
thank you
what's happening
again we're getting the time on our side
we're incrementally moving in that
direction I like where Ray has taken
this so far a bit of a you know dubious
opening I've heard so far from the
squads but I think we're shaping up to
be okay how's the team spirit after it
is amazing at the momentum we're going
for it this is going to happen I can
feel it yeah we're good excellent
excellent good luck
[Music]
did you task uh Wesley with distracting
Levon was that the plan as always yes
Wesley is the perfect get him off the
board seems Innocent but uh he's uh he's
actually the uh the team assassin
they're just unexpected so yeah yes
that Greg black I mean they left him
with five seconds the last game and then
they expect him to play fast
that's way too much all right pass pass
the torch the torch of uh blame blame
was only the first game who's to blame
for for the second game well I think
it's a combination yeah this was their
team effort but I think Fabian left too
little time and spent like three minutes
thinking
all right it's a collective effort of
course
they you know there is a lesson to this
don't try to play like your opponents
they thought that the design they're
gonna get a nice position no no it's
only for special players
but it didn't work out very well for you
guys last game doesn't matter even
though we got a good position we had an
amazing position
now we have beautiful blocking black is
slightly better
so you're feeling good about the chances
how's uh the morale within the team
after that painful loss
it's okay it happens
we just need to
you know use the advantage of this
position
very good
all right
come on
yes
exactly this is the bookie that I was
looking for where is she looking for the
blockade
I like 98.
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of disputing ideas in this
position how do you feel Bobby
I think it's an equal position equal
which is good for us because we're
better players
so in equal position is good
so you got out of the opening
no prep in this one
no this was prep this was also Browns
okay
so it in fact all prep all the time
yeah this was also prepared all right
you're switching teams
[Laughter]
dangerous combination
so you want to replace one Sam yeah
I think a reputation is not so bad it's
probably just huh
white is better
white is better okay
I'm not making sure I heard right
thank you
they're here reminds you of the dates
when you played the tarash no I mean now
you have it with an extra Tempo you're
happy
[Laughter]
look the dude beat me with the tarash
man
mix it exactly 40 years ago mixed 1983.
yeah 40 years ago he remembers
oh my gosh did you hear that
memorized our game
poor bastard
ruined his chest restart terrible
[Laughter]
started what was your first game do you
memorized yes sir do you remember yeah I
still to this day remember that I
memorized the Opera game okay from Paul
Murphy and the crazy part about that is
after I memorized the game and I thought
I was really familiar with everything
then fine gold pointed out
that morpheme missed a simple win
like like the simplest win of all
remember when the guy goes Queen E7
in the Opera game he defends F7 I think
so well and the idea is if you go Queen
takes B7 there's Queen B4 chat right
okay yeah well Ben says why don't you
just go Bishop takes F7 check
and I was like
and I had memorized the game and I still
then found something I'd never realized
occurred
but yeah that was my first uh memorized
game
no don't ask me
Martin's always focused Total Focus
in the second game played an important
part in that you defended very
accurately oh thank you for evening
right now you're trying to get a hold of
this position what is uh
what is your instinct telling you about
yourself alleged I think the last one
was very good from Sam
but maybe you go like Bishop B5 here and
still think it's on that last decent
position
so still very complex position every
single game has been extremely extremely
close did you expect that going into the
matches I did actually well game one I
don't know if you can say it was that
close but as I said earlier I think
it'll be a very close match everybody
seems to be giving it the role with the
trash talk but also with the chess moves
did you do any special preparation for
this one
uh no I just came here looking to have
fun oh wow this is very interesting
okay
what do we see right now
what do you uh what are you calculating
this is nine of five B4 is an idea I'm
not sure that's what he plays okay all
right well let's get back to the action
we'll let you think
tense
every single game has been extremely
very close did you expect that
um it's just very close most teams are
pretty much equal but we still haven't
yet
at least you still claim to have the yes
show the confidence I like it love it
yes
I don't believe why it can be better
I don't believe you Curry
I believe you mostly but not this time
their idea was before no no just now
then he attacks your queen being four
and when you calculated Queen A3 95 and
now watch your calculation that's it
okay that's it I'm not losing material
that's what I thought well you want a
pawn because if he takes your Rook you
take the Rook with checks
what did he play
he played like this is like in the
correct move was actually which is very
difficult to I think it's the right roof
was given Advantage probably was Bishop
maybe I don't know Bishop takes D6 yeah
and then I'd be five but then takes on
C1 nights I mean Jesus was Bishop of
five right
slightly better but you wanted to be
aggressive you see aggression
it's key it's key
Jeffrey and Lavon coming up next
time
oh yeah okay
[Laughter]
in Spain
okay the Federation president kissed the
the player and it was a big scandal in
chess
it means wonderful things just happen
because things just happened
it's like scoring a goal it's a goal
a good kiss
so the coin is there's good kisses and
bad kisses you just you just gotta know
your audience
I like
oh yeah
you like it I like it it's slow until
beautiful it's a nice end game yes
it's soft you know what they say about
the kids nowadays you know the end games
having some difficulties with that is
experience going to play a role is
Jeffrey still a kid I don't even know
what's happening here Jeffrey is a
brilliant player
and uh
when somebody is so strong you can
hardly call them a kid anymore
I haven't called uh Jeffrey a kid since
he was 10. yeah
and he start beating you by another yes
yes that's that's right
I grew up with him in Texas
nobody's laughing anymore
[Music]
this is more straightforward
no subtlety
once
I think the one thing for a girl no
never
mind
I think Gary got the game plan all the
way to the very end right now yes I want
to have fun
foreign
thank you
Hikaru with the time taking down how are
you feeling about this hanging
someone will wander
who's going to put on someone well
someone will blunder
hopefully not
confidence
Alex with time ticking down what's
Happening Here we're all in control it's
just on on coasting mode right now good
luck
I think
in wrecks We Trust yes
[Applause]
squeezing yes
you like that mode
yes it's a squeezing
just asking a question he's also playing
fast yes very well he learned that you
lose on time I know that's the end of
the game that's how it works a painful
lesson in the second game yes yes but he
made the adjustments yeah well you know
at 80 years old you can still teach it
all about New Tricks not yet there
just 79.
I was so close on that one
beating my average
[Applause]
some spicy moves there yeah yeah sure
hey where where is that good ship hey
wait wait wait a minute we're ready
[Laughter]
guys
I need my Prodigy to hear hear what it
was just said
to be unprofessional for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
very nice very nice Wesley was provoked
to say that Alex you played better than
me and I was provoked to explain the
obvious as well well that wasn't hard
thank you
the income might go down but my spirits
might be a lot higher Alex things seem
to be going your way but your team's
away right now he told me that I still
have a shot like I I could still get my
you know professional hat in the ring so
I'm I'm feeling pretty uplifted right
now and I like our I like our position
we're looking good here and I know Ray's
gonna getting that time back momentum
love it as you rightly pointed out if
you do go that route your income
probably will go a little bit down
but your self-confidence definitely up I
think my boss might be watching this
stream so I think I should probably uh
cut it off there about my ambition
nobody's retiring nobody is Rita I
wasn't tiring anymore
[Laughter]
right
great feeling depression
by 20 more
minutes
said that once you get quiet things are
not looking good for your team
I will be loud
yes you have confidence here yes
what happened where do you go wrong
I shouldn't have played last actively
with the Rook probably because they
weakened some squares and then it was
difficult for Rex too to find the Right
Moves
boy talk about a cheapo
[Laughter]
linear those types of tactics
thank you
all tied up after two games this game
three after this one we only have one
left this one is the key moment right
now okay this is crucial yeah
but uh oh yeah Rex what's happening in
case of a tie
did you what's the tie
no ties allowed to me it's a club you
wear around your neck
26 seconds team rex
a minute and 15 demands that's fine
um
[Music]
Shanklin substitution
Al
Alexis Alex oh boy okay all right
thank you
[Applause]
not easy
these are not easy moves to last
yeah
and what's the problem
[Music]
this is looking really bad Carlos played
this super well like really well and uh
Gary you're happy
[Laughter]
[Music]
here
[Applause]
why did I have to play with big airplane
hello
these guys
[Laughter]
no
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
going into the last one how are you
feeling about your chances it's been
back and forth okay I just you know I'm
just it's uh it's good to get some
physical sense of the pieces so that's
what I just yes they get because I said
for one year so My yeah that's uh I
never I never played any any real games
always chess pieces tomorrow it's a good
warm-up for uh yeah yeah no I played
tons of games online but that's not the
same okay I'm getting adjusted very nice
thank you
ready
Rex down to one this is it
you feel you're going tomorrow in the
comeback yes this is it as you said
Alex
two in a row we gotta have level heads
play the Right Moves I think we're gonna
pull through here we just gotta make
sure that we're staying on point if
you're heading the game and finish the
job that's the plan that's the plan good
luck guys
[Music]
game four is just about the beginning
the final game of this exciting match
[Music]
E5 woo
no more Karo Khan
probably tough losses man
yeah down to the one this one we'll come
back here there's no doubt no doubt
how about the opening he switched from
the caracon some sort of affiliate great
this is classic
it's improving the classics you think
Rex knows the classics I think so I
think he's well educated and he's bread
and butter absolutely
foreign
to the best of my ability and try to put
my team in a position to uh Propel from
some type of a foundation so hopefully
uh we're keeping our Pawn structured
were you worried the Rex got some hints
in between the games
I felt unprepared I know that my team I
mean where's my coaching
their coach yeah nobody behind me so
I don't know where those guys are
they're around here one of them is right
oh well of course I mean the man the
managing submits with Gary I mean how
cool is that I mean I'm a nobody and I'm
standing here next to Gary kaspara
was you put him in a good position
because he finished the game last night
he did that's definitely held the team
spirit I think I heard the word
excellent uh so I you know I think I
could go to heaven that is call it good
there from Gary so I felt good about
that just life complete
completed all the side quests now that's
it Gary casparo excellent move okay I'm
good
[Music]
150 years whatever probably in your
first uh few years
yeah exactly that's one of the one of
the first books I read
my parents met each other
game against uh I wonder right is a
competition
no it's different this position was in a
symbol I mean they're discussing playing
this against some strong players upon
Spirits are a bit low
let's cheer up a little bit we're upset
but uh sometimes it's a good thing you
know to be upset and you know that kind
of the emotion will drive you
yes sir go what any pep talk for
foreign's feeling it I mean it's it's
it's rough out there it's tough it's
tough and then you die what does he have
to do to turn it around
the team needs some inspiration uh I
don't know what's missing but it's the X
Factor
broadcast on the structure of the double
pawns on C6 and C7 are am I crazy you
did I feel like you did like three or
four years ago I think so yeah
you guys are gonna have to read my books
to be inspired I mean
it was for uh I know you're a number
that's the inspiration
I have to ask for permission
Chris who's next Fabi and Jeffrey
you're back you're feeling like you're
back yes we're winning this one
I don't want to make the blame again
who's next Bobby Bobby and um
you can trust you can trust Fabi
when there is space he's Unstoppable
is Unstoppable I mean he's a beast what
about Inside the Cage
you like how I'm trash talking my own
thing
this is what is needed to turn it turn
it around yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think I don't think I'm allowed to
play it
I mean other perspectives
E5 is mating now chapter 75 is just
mating neither five bye bye
if they cannot defense so they have to
play G5
Smile by Wesley he doesn't know what to
believe
doesn't know what's real and what's not
Wesley
assessment
[Laughter]
we're winning don't make us forfeit now
okay my bad no one told us the rules
what they were thinking maybe you can
try
I have them written some around here
of course
yes
at least to build some some resistance
foreign
Montana
[Applause]
everybody
all right Rex first stage of the game
out of the way a big lead on the clock
nine minutes against five minutes that
must feel pretty good in Balance
position what do you think oh man I
whites got it whites just got it chances
are looking good to turn it around
equalize the score yeah yes absolutely
beautiful
[Applause]
it's great I thought what black was on
the attack with the pawn on G4 and Levon
was explaining to the to the cognacente
uh it would actually be pretty good if
the pawn was on G7
release the beast puppy your inner your
inner beasts at least the Beast ie
what does that mean
yes yes open the gate
have you ever released the beast in the
game of chess I I'm sure I have I can't
remember it
I think as Lavon said you know it's been
a long time since I won a term so I mean
I don't remember the beast
on the receiving end of the Beast
I know it's good it's good it's good he
doesn't know you're just a substitute
right Reserve Reserve thank you reserve
Reserve substitute sounds somewhat
strange but a reserve you know you know
you have this uh the these uh wines that
are held back the reserve you only bring
them in when necessary and we're totally
required H4 that is that five is that uh
releasing the Beast
I mean
[Applause]
is the Beast released no no the Beast is
in the cage
but he's getting hungry he's getting
hungry okay okay
[Applause]
sometimes we actually think he deserves
his rating
all right
perfect
[Music]
well you're just about to enter the game
and potentially release the beast your
own business yes
horses
you talk about the horses lots of
pastures Green Pastures yes there's so
much grass for My Horses so
very excited
hey Ray
oh okay here we go
all right
seems to be very happy he's talking
about Green Pastures for his horses
what do you see going in your favor in
this position I feel he is
overestimating his uh his delightfulness
at the moment we got we got Ray at the
board I know he's going to come up with
some great things here and
just a minute oh see I wasn't expecting
that so I don't know
what about the time
we got to get back a little bit we got
to get back into the swing of things
with our time play a little bit uh
more directly but I think we're okay
but I think I'm next
unclear who's next uh Lanier and ikawaru
okay and then Alex
I'll take the extra five moves there we
go especially after her car
that'd be a good he'll leave me in a
good spot I feel
um
[Music]
all that talk about these cages what was
he talking about what was uh Lebron
talking about what does he know and we
don't I have no idea
you know I think they got a bit lucky
Wesley was uh
playing some very bad moves which ended
up being good moves I don't know how but
they ended up being good moves
that G5 G4 yeah
yeah
so how are you feeling about the chances
right now still pretty good
anymore
window
you're getting tense Wesley what is it
actually
yeah it happened before
no but also yeah issues with the time
yeah yeah and we have the time it's a
problem
oh my God but we got when we got an
excellent position but it cannot be a
good
sound like anymore yeah anymore yeah no
that's great that's perfect don't listen
to him
now he can go back and he will go back I
will never go back
one more for you
sir
you're about to get in the saddle I mean
I don't know what Wesley's doing we're
not Wesley sorry Ray Ray is doing I
don't know what he's doing oh hold on
before
and then H5 so what I mean the Knight
has to go to a for them I get stuck on
the edge of the board yeah exactly but I
mean even without that I mean because
now that I can go back to you too also
like the night's not not out of the game
yeah
that's the problem I feel like we want
more games so maybe if I didn't get like
Armageddon
I'm not sure there is an arc yet
okay
[Applause]
basically
together
big tense moments right now next few
moves are going to be critical
[Music]
yes it's a classic
team Alex right now going into the last
few minutes of game four the last game
is leading by one game one point two to
the one if team rex wins this one
score is going to be equal and we're
potentially going to go into a tie
breaks
we're still confirming what the tie
breaks are going to be looking like if
there will be tie breaks we will get
back to that shortly but for the moment
big big tense few moves coming up
our producers are right now
potentially voting for a coin flip I
don't think that's going to happen but
let's just wait and see what's going to
happen in this game right now
[Laughter]
how are you feeling about position
chances to get back in this one for team
racks yeah no for sure I mean three
three results are are certainly possible
in this one but whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa uh we just saw a
remarkable decision by
like Hikaru there like
it's just exposed as king I mean he
lifted his kimono and
it's not a good look it's not a good
look
[Laughter]
at it
sometimes we just have to take the mic
away from you yeah sir just the way it
goes
hopeful a few more pieces would be off
of the board by now
very complicated position coming up and
you're just about to get in the Saddles
oh final final thoughts
just got to keep my composure move fast
you heard it
I'm almost not sure what to look for now
because uh you don't really want to be
the person their birthday at the same
time on the other team
[Music]
s
have done this because it's too hard to
play yeah
no I mean after 95 he takes a five could
I play Queen E3 Chuck too how bad is
that I mean that that's bad but I don't
know if that's so bad you still keep the
four pawns together D6 C6 B5 A5 yeah
yeah maybe that's the best I actually
2K14 H7 D5 yeah yeah something like that
but it's hard to do yeah
it's okay
three minutes right now for team wrecks
one minute for team Alex
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
so what's happening here what's
happening Happening Here well depends on
Alex Alex what's happening
yeah don't lose sometimes
Gary
[Applause]
yeah because basically a place
well Alex was the star he won both of
the games from the equal positions he
was a star
what was the problem why did Sam
Shanklin resign at the end oh because
we're gonna get a pass on and promote to
a queen
um Rex was too happy to trade off he's
the one who's actually needed to attack
he sort of misunderstood what was going
on so it worked out it was good but Alex
was a story he won both the two two
games we started a little bit worse
we're back close to equal and then he
won them so he deserves all the credit
Alex will get back to you in just a
second
Rex I have to ask you what went wrong in
in this one
you know there's problems all over the
world we can't worry about a few
problems here on the chessboard when the
world's all screwed up China's attack
you know we've got to put things in
perspective still I have to tell you he
gave them a gift Rex first of all I have
to tell you uh happy birthday thank you
just an amazing event another great year
of just here in St Louis with a
grandchild tour with all these amazing
players coming along what are the plans
for the future and how are you seeing
the future of course English Jessica I'm
gonna go into hiding
and now we're going to get
the final interview with uh Our Winning
Captain Alex Carefree Alex
congratulations first time on ultimate
moves thank you and a big victory for
you oh how are you feeling right now
well I mean this is like a dream come
true looking out amongst this crowd and
many of the people like I mean Yasser
Gary people that when I was growing up
inspired me to even get involved in the
game and now all of these modern Heroes
it's just been a real pleasure so thank
you Rex to host me here on your birthday
uh it's been absolutely phenomenal thank
you Alex for everything you're doing for
chess here in St Louis with a corporate
chess League you're attracting a lot of
influence here in St Louis and Across
the Nation so thank you very much Alex
yeah still time to sign up September
28th sign up your team get six players
corporate chess League starts up again
so excited for that
exciting tournament all around
incredible event here is your final
score three to one for team Alex carefor
join us tomorrow we will be back at 2PM
with chess 9lx it's going to be a
fantastic event we have the best chess
players in the United States and of
course the one and only Gary kasperov
don't miss it we'll be back tomorrow see
you guys there
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited